[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: The more we
understand the neurochemistry
of lived experience,
the more we realize
that we don't get to
ever really sample
any kind of objective
reality, right?
Reality is coupled
to perception,
and perception can
be mediated, right?
Certain music can change
the way we process a scene.
A moment can seem
truthful or dishonest,
depending on the tone,
depending on whether it's
cloudy or sunny, depending
on the place in which you
happen to dwell, right?
So again, reality is
mediated by perception.
Perception can be manipulated.
And so brilliant people-- people
who change the world-- leaders,
right-- are said to have
this thing known as a reality
distortion field, right?
Steve Jobs was
made famous for it.
His ability to distort.
To italicize perception
in his co-workers, right?
To inspire somebody to see
the world in a new way, right?
To literally engage the
attention of all these body
minds, and present with them
an alternative universe.
To make people-- to bring
them into your world,
to suck them into
your trance, right,
and literally engage them to
probe the adjacent possible.
To gnaw at that
shadow future that
hovers over the present, that
provides a map of all the ways
the present can reinvent itself.
That's what leaders do.
They distort reality.
But here's the thing.
There's nothing fake--
there's nothing inauthentic--
about distorting reality,
because the distorted reality
becomes real the moment
that perception becomes
the main operating system.
The moment you adopt that vision
as truth, it becomes truth.
Mankind decided we would
fly, it became truth.
Mankind creates technology
that folds space and time so
that minds can communicate
instantaneously
across digital screens, somebody
hallucinated this technology
into being.
We live in a world where
our thoughts spill over,
and if they can harness the
will of the people around us,
we can labor new
realities into being.
We can usher new
worlds into being.
We can author realities.
Because we, as humans beings,
our greatest potential,
is that we have this
reality distortion field.
We are like Neo in "The
Matrix" when he sees the code,
and he flexes his muscle,
and space and time
warps around him.
Powerful metaphor,
but that's who we are.
That's what we are.
[MUSIC PLAYING]